James Charles is flying out 10 people to
be in his ad campaign don't get on that
plane please I want to fly 10 of you
plane this is the beginning of like saw
12. so when it came time to figure out
who's actually going to be in the
campaign
confidence
I'm looking for 10 people who love
makeup and who are confused about their
sexuality to submit to submit your
application please send a picture of
your armpit hair send your applications
via Snapchat DMS please thank you very
much it doesn't matter if it's perfect I
think James we're over the fan
interactions no more reaching out no
more fan collabs this is this is just
not acceptable so anyway we'll follow
this and see if the 10 winners aren't
like young young boys that